I'd like to invite Dr Mohit mazumdar who
will also be the other program Mentor
for the chem informatics program he has
over 12 years of research and Industry
hearing and he has completed a masters
in buying chromatic from Jamia Jamia
milia islamia and has a PHD in
computational biology and chemistry from
jawaharlal nehru University he is an
expert in machine learning and
application to biomedical and chemical
data so without further delay let's
start with today's section so the stage
is all yours
uh thank you SRI gauri and thank you so
much Dr puneet for uh giving us that
clarity about how the training program
would be and why we should be all
excited about it because it's a it's a
time where technology is evolving at a
rapid play pace and uh at the same time
we are finding new things new details
and uh doing discoveries so it's a great
time to learn this and start applying
because the opportunities are like that
only where the industry is providing the
right kind of opportunity if you have
the right kind of skills and experience
so um thank you again
um for joining today's session and uh
for uh I'm really excited here today to
meet with you all who are interested in
utilizing modern data analysis tools
learning and exploring the 2D
two-dimensional as well as the
three-dimensional space to find the
answers to the problems of drug
Discovery so um we have been discussing
the in the session that how
this training program would be so uh as
Dr paneer said correctly that it
involves the traditional are learning
about the basics learning about what all
technologies have been used so far in
drug Discovery and what are the case
studies where this success has happened
in this utilizing drug data-driven drug
Discovery so we will be exploring
uh techniques that will involve us to
utilize more uh both two dimensional and
three-dimensional space so it's really
exciting to be able to do that and
develop such skill sets as well so um
about the entire process
um
so uh we will get to the questions also
um in this session so in this
presentation what will be covered in my
part of the presentation and uh we will
have we'll find time for the to address
the question so please feel free to put
your questions in the chat and we'll be
able to address them uh in between
so as I was telling you that the process
of drug Discovery it demands the
selection of disease as we all know
Target hypothesis so what would be the
Target and the hypothesis behind the
Target and searching for potential
compounds that is that would be helpful
for us to reduce the severity of the
disease to any extent right so these are
some of the very critical components
when we think about drug Discovery in
general and then there are different
stages in there so lead identification
is a stage preclinical trial is a stage
clinical trial is a stage and then one
one could say that pharmacogenomic
optimization is also a stage so what are
the different opportunities now and
challenges that the industry is facing
uh because when there is uh uh like
opportunities and when there are
challenges you will find also the
opportunities there so one of the very
uh talked about uh discipline that you
might have been hearing or research
areas Precision medicine so personalized
medicine and why this program is a
modern data Discovery or data
drug Discovery program is because of
that because we are not only thinking
about drug Discovery as a traditional
way of looking at it but also a modern
way of looking at it why what what are
the different ways that we can enhance
and reduce the time as well as find
meaningful answers without getting fail
getting failed in that process so
Precision medicine drug design is an
exciting field drug repurposing is an
exciting field so in this presentation
we will learn about
the modern drug Discovery pipeline that
we've been discussing about the chem
informatics and data driven drug
Discovery the training part and the
project part uh thus the schedule of the
online training and the research how are
we going to do it what are the ways one
could register and what is the
sustainable sustainability cost for us
and also the advancements and the use of
Cutting Edge technology so from machine
learning deep learning to utilizing
um
other
known data driven Technologies uh all
those options are there it would be it
would be based on the progress how you
progress and how you interact with us
and learn through this entire process so
um a little bit of introduction
um
so the drug Discovery program that we
have started which is the camera
informative biomedical drug Discovery
and this is the current version uh we
started this program into
2020 where we collaborated with the
Pharma industry and one of the
e associate partner of us to be able to
do this is the Faba Academy so Farber
Academy along with their mentors we
designed an uh part we first partnered
and then we designed topics and
curriculums and learning modules that
will be more relevant for the students
because it's driven from the industry
experts from the industry leaders from
the industry so the first course that we
did in 2000 uh 2020
included advisors from uh different uh
companies who have Rich background
working with large big Pharma and
biotechnology companies and now our
co-founders and Founders and are working
in this space and you have already met
Dr puneet and you will also find video
presentations by Dr Ajit Kama Dr Uday
saxena and if we get an opportunity if
you start working on your own project
then we will have a discussion and we
will have them as also help you in this
entire learning and research training
program that we are just inviting all
you to join so that's about the
conceptualization and how all of this
has started it started with an industry
aspect and it focuses on the gaps that
are not uh being filled in the education
or other trainings that are available
so a little bit about
um the modern biomedical drug Discovery
Pipeline and how things have changed so
people who are learning drug Discovery
they know about docking they know they
have heard about simulations molecular
modeling Alpha fold and all but they
these are tools so before the tool I
think it's very much important to
understand that why we are doing this
what is the what is how we are doing
this is something that will come next
but why we are doing this and what all
we can do is very important to know so
that's why this omix logic training
program is a great opportunity because
you get to know not only from the drug
Discovery aspects but but from a genetic
or a more detailed uh like from a more
detailed data that will tell you that
why this the why there is a gene why
there is a mutation and why what has the
the what is the effect of that mutation
it will help you to find new targets so
genomics and biomedical data sets they
help us identify for example biomarkers
now there is a company called DNA Nexus
that just that focuses only on this like
genomic and biomedical data sets they
use and they identify biomarkers and
they focus on drug discovery
so another important Rich area to find
uh you know information to start your
work or to find something new is through
the scientific literature so scientific
articles to identify Target ID you know
there are large number of companies and
they just focuses on this that
identifying articles and the conference
presentations and from the value that
the academicians are generating and to
find the identify drug targets that are
relevant for the industry so
several companies work on that even in
India another aspect so tumor sample
data to identify prognostic biomarkers
so this is predictive oncology huge
application in oncology as for the known
reasons uh very complex disease and uh
very less recovery uh so a lot of uh
opportunities are there in terms of
digging the data finding the right kind
of Target and then targeting molecules
for that kind of Target medical
literature and symptoms symptom drug
data for drug repurposing so we've been
talking about drug repurposing also so
the drugs that have been already
approved if they are working for other
indications how do we know that what is
the method so there are companies like
helix
who are focused just on that cellular
fluorescent Imaging data for richer in
vitro pharmacology so there is a company
called recursion that works on that
protein structural data to identify
peptide binders so there's a company
called maintain.ai that focuses on that
so protein structural data and compound
binding for small molecules with
generation atom wise is a company that
works on that so as I'm telling you that
like different disciplines so even a
micro discipline within a discipline is
enough for a company to you know work on
that finding different types of
uh ways to assist the drug Discovery
process so the opportunities are so much
in this space uh one would need a uh
understanding of how to work with the
data how to analyze and find meaningful
way to analyze the data so we've been
discussing about the application of
modern biomedical drug Discovery for
example in personalized medicine so
personalized or Precision medicine
initiating from Clinical and like for
example for from clinical data from from
molecular pharmacological data so it it
introduces a new era in healthcare and
it aims to identify and predict the
optimal treatment for a patient or for a
cohort
so this is also like uh earlier called
evidence-based medicine so
evidence-based medicine integrates
information uh which is which is what
you see in Vivo and which is what you
see in the observational studies which
is what you see in clinical trials up to
the meta-analysis for the clinical
consideration so
this is uh to understand the population
gen also like the average of the
population and uh there are many
companies who are intensively working on
this to understand the pharmacological
aspects and different aspects that could
help them in Noble uh drug Discovery
novel drug Discovery drug Delivery
Systems and also drug repurposing so
um the research This research will allow
us like will allow you to utilize both
experimental or clinical data so you you
have that understanding that how things
are working in in real world and then
design a project so many of us are come
from an academic background and many of
those projects are not translational in
aspect so one of the things that we are
trying to do here in atomics logic is to
work on translational problems so that's
a also an opportunity
now uh application like understanding
for example uh I this is just to
elaborate on that understanding that how
for example transcriptomics so
transcriptomics is to understand the
transcriptome which is the gene
expression patterns and uh how do we
find out things it's very simple like
when you compare so understanding the
consequences of an individual
transcriptomics variation a individual
means a patient uh which which differs
from any other patient so understanding
an individual's transcriptomics
variation is kind of fundamental today
to disappear the human biology and
disease because this data is something
that you need to look at to understand
and like gain all the insights that you
might require so gene expression
patterns in association with clinical
data can help identify molecular
biomarkers for Diagnostics and for
therapy selections so new discoveries
include a better understanding of these
complex diseases at a subcellular level
as well as Target identification for
Noble drug targeting or drug designing
or repurposing so uh this multiomics
approach is the modern drug discovery
that uses you know from sequence to
structure from home mix insights to
understand the cellular
cellular interplay uh protein protein
complex interaction understanding the
entire uh you know
um environment which is the system
biology approach and then trying to
mimicking that environment which is
through molecular Dynamic simulation so
that's after that you have all the
computational tools in between you are
doing the discovery in between you're
trying to model and find the right kind
of complex which is also a difficult
task because there are so many small
consideration you have to make when you
are trying to mimic something within on
within an organism for example within a
host how the molecules are acting within
inside our body they are not stagnant
they are moving all the time there is
Dynamics involved so how do we able to
do predict that
and that and to predict them correctly
is a challenge so and that's why we are
here uh to as a mentor and we are
developed we have developed all these
sessions and uh materials and uh
utilizing the research which is ongoing
the current research and our own
experience to help guide students
achieve and learn these technologies
that will be really helpful in the
future and also now so uh from Target
Discovery we've been discussing about
Target Discovery so we discussed about
how different types of uh clinical
samples cell line data cell model data
patient samples animal model data can
help us in that process of you know
Target identification then Target
validation and then go for drug
Discovery so this initial phase is
critically important if you are thinking
about an entire big project or if you
want to work on a small project also in
some of these Associated areas
now um about the training that we are
going to start uh the cheminformatics
for biomedical drug Discovery has all
those aspects so quickly we will get to
an understanding of how the application
of machine learning algorithms are there
how the application of different types
of approaches are there we'll start with
an overview of that and then I'll tell
you about the sessions how the sessions
are planned and what will be what we
will be covering in the sessions and how
that translates into a independent
research or how that translates into
research
foreign
one of the things that has happened uh
in the recent past and uh if if you guys
have any question feel free to write it
in the chat and during this presentation
um so uh I might maybe before I start
this section just take a look at the
questions if there are any
[Music]
um
how can one incorporate chem informatics
a dry lab process with animal study a
wet lab uh so as I'm as I was telling
you that
what wet lab studies are doing are
helping is they are helping in
generating data any wet lab experiment
will generate some data and once you
have that data it's a dry lab process so
it's all correlated you just have to
know that what kind of data you're
generating with dry wet lab experiments
if you know about if it is a cancer
related research and if you are
generating some data with that bitlab
experiments you can reach out to us and
we can discuss how that data can be
further you know how your even
experiments can be designed Based on
data so the approach has changed
completely now now we look at data first
and then we design experiments and
that's how we are cutting the cost
earlier we were doing virtual screening
with millions and millions of compounds
now it's knowledge driven we know that
okay this is the active group this is
how the molecule should look like these
are the different molecules that are
good binders so we go with information
and knowledge and then we go for a
specific experiments so it is called
what it is help helping is in is that it
is helping in reducing the cost so much
like from these high throughput
experiments here when you're where
you're trying everything against
everything now you are very focused and
then the chances and the probability of
your success is also very high because
it's knowledge driven
uh Dave preet uh there's a question so
we are posting these jobs on our own mix
logic portal also so we'll share that
job listing and you'll be able to see
that in the portal itself but uh we also
have a LinkedIn group where I share
about these job opportunities all the
time like every day
um so you'll find jobs there also and uh
like you can also search out look for
yourself with these keywords and you'll
find jobs uh and postdoctoral
opportunities PhD opportunities even
Master scholarships and all of that
through this sort of training we have
students who have completed it and uh
they they have gone to do higher degrees
in very reputed universities through
recommendation and through the
experience
yeah I think our team member they
they've prayed our team members will be
able to yeah thank you shubham and
please help Dave preet
all right so now going back to the
second phase of this so I wanted to
discuss the application of machine
learning algorithms in different uh
aspects so in most drug Discovery
projects what happens is that Pro the
protein is uh chosen as a drug Target
right for the development of
Therapeutics so that's how we know
things like so several supervised and
unsupervised machine learning approaches
have been used for structural prediction
at different levels of analysis so we
are first talking about structure
prediction so if you don't have a
structure which is
your drug Target how do we how do you
predict that structure so that is
something that comes first but if you
already have a crystallized or structure
predicted structure or uh sorry
experimental structure then obviously
there is a high probability that
um because all the atoms have been
mapped with an experimental uh map which
has been generated through maybe
extractography or anima spectroscopy or
cryo em so these are experimental
methods and if you have a structure
which is uh derived experimentally then
the probability of all the atoms present
at that 3D space is very high so you get
like maybe you it you get better results
but then again uh when you're doing
modeling
the structure that we get from modeling
is also very detailed we just have to
make sure that it's properly modeled so
some manual maneuver is important in
that in that context you look for uh
Missing residues because many times what
happens in modeling is that uh in
crystallography there are some regions
where there is no electron density so in
that case you have to find and build
those areas so how to make sure that
those are stereochemically uh uh
physically uh like stable low energy so
all those considerations are important
when we are thinking about
um
um uh like predictions so in as I was
telling you that uh again like
predictions happen at different levels
so primary sequence of amino acids uh
then uh finding the secondary structure
from the primary uh structure analysis
from there a primary amino acids so from
you have 20 amino acids and your string
of uh them uh as a protein sequence then
you want to predict that how they are
going to fold so whether they will be
alphysis whether or there will be beta
sheets or there will be coil or Loops
how do that's a prediction that is uh it
that's how it starts from the secondary
structure prediction then the tertiary
structure prediction that how it is
going to fold in a three-dimensional uh
uh format form so the problem of protein
folding so you're trying to solve that
and then quarterly quaternary structures
and protein protein structures how it is
interacting with other three-dimensional
structures and how it happens what are
the insights that you can get so machine
learning algorithms are used for
secondary structure prediction solvent
accessibility prediction so what is the
solvent how many areas in the protein
where solvent can be accessible so your
solvent could be water also
so to find out through the groups and
all and then topology generation contact
map generation which finally integrates
this knowledge into building a 3D model
of the target so supervised machine
learning methods like svm and DT
algorithms they you they are used for
rule generation training data set for
secondary structure prediction
artificial neural network is used to
predict distances between the pair of
amino acid residues which is used to
contract construct the potential of mean
forces for generating protein shapes so
these are all published study that I'm
talking about and the Machine learning
methods are also used for fold
recognition and model evaluation
evaluation so then we have a molecular
or 3D building techniques or like the
algorithms that have been really used
from from very very beginning like
conjugate gradient gradient descent
model so the conjugate decent gradient
model is also used in
uh energy minimization Monte Carlo
methods are used in optimization energy
minimization as well as 3D model
building so these methods are uh these
algorithms or methods are like
traditional algorithms and now they are
working with the machine learning
algorithms so in model generation you
get to work with like different types of
algorithms then you have heard about
Alpha fold from deepmind then that
performed well and they created models
uh and they have now a database where
they have predicted all the models in
association with
embl so uh what are the different
limitations and all we will also learn
about that but like as you have learned
like have a now clear understanding I
guess of what is the application of
machine learning for primary sequence of
Target proteins now the second is ligand
molecule you could see that what are the
like ligand from how do we go like we
learned about one one thing which is
from
um structure to finding those Inhibitors
and molecules now from in from the other
approach uh for example I'll tell give
you this ligand molecule the others the
right side of the panel
so uh a single bio bioactive ligand can
be used as an input to search for a vast
set of similar compounds so you have a
you have a known drug and it's a
bioactive drug and it's working really
well now you want to find similar
compounds in the chemical databases so
machine learning approaches such as
kernel discrimination and nave-based
Bayesian classifier methods are used for
such virtual screening by analyzing the
property of the bioactive part so
similarly compounds are searched scored
and screened based on the distance based
similarity functional group matching
with the bioactive input bioactive
compound and then that distance based
approach as well so this includes like
you know chemical fingerprinting
functional group like a shape
pharmacophore and all of that
so this is an overview of all the things
that are happening and advancements and
uh integration of the methods that have
been used such as uh for ligand-based
searching now we will learn little bit
about the other two ways which is like
denovo design of molecules with desired
property so this is also a very hot
topic and it's being used by some of the
AI based companies such as in silica
medicine to generate molecules of
desired properties so computational
approaches can be used to generate
chemical molecules as well with desired
physiochemical and biological properties
so supervised machine learning
algorithms are used for training the
model to generate chemically feasible
Smiley strings so smile is a format to
generate or to write
chemical structures and also for
accessing the biological property of the
compound so there is a process there's a
there's a deep learning method called
reinforcement learning for structural
evaluation which is a deep enforced
reinforcement learning based method and
also there are graph theories which are
used for all of this so this is this was
a brief overview of the advancement that
one could use but uh for those who are
starting and those who are who are
beginners obviously uh we will not go to
the advanced steps just like that so in
this training program we will cover from
a very basic like we are very beginner
level where we have started where I have
started understanding what are the basic
things and how to understand and relate
from this basic understanding two
different stages like from basic to 2D
space to 3D space and then machine
learning deep learning molecular
Dynamics all of that so it's an exciting
Journey it's uh and very uh visual
because we will be doing Hands-On uh in
throughout the throughout the training
program because it's mostly Hands-On and
very less theoretical in aspect because
uh Theory you can always read and learn
from research Publications and Google